next we have John Elton's is the
associate commissioner of survey methods
for survey methods research at the U of
Labor Statistics his principal research
interests include integration of
multiple data sources classification and
regression trees for complex data small
domain estimation and measurement error
models he received a PhD from the
Department of Statistics at Iowa State
University thank you for joining us okay
thanks very much Ellen and like to thank
the organizers for the opportunity to
speak here this is the first chance I've
had to attend a Wolfram data summit it's
been very enlightening enjoyed it a
great deal and looking forward to
further conversations in addition I
appreciate being placed at this point on
the program because I've been eagerly
taking notes with the previous
presentations on saying gee I can tie it
in here tie in here like that so it's
nice to have a chance to pull together
some of those threads as the title
indicates I'm talking about linking data
quality with customer value and in
particular I'm going to be framing that
through three main steps first of all
we'll say a little bit about government
statistical agencies I work at the
bureau of labor statistics but the
experience I'll be describing are
qualitatively similar to what many of
our partner agencies like the Census
Bureau National Center for Health
Statistics a number of other statistical
agencies in for example Sweden United
Kingdom and elsewhere in the world I
have also been experiencing and in
particular experiences we've been having
as we've started to wrestle with a
question about the extent of ways in
which we might be able to make
productive use of big data to fulfill
our mission in ways both cost-effective
meet some other criteria that we have
that in turn is going to lead into some
discussion of linkage between the
general notions of data quality that our
agencies and again based on the
discussions we've been seeing here over
the last couple of days I believe also
many of our other stakeholders and other
people here in the room have been
wrestling with in terms of formal
definitions of data quality and linking
that with specific ideas that we have
about customer value and the value we
deliver to particular data users and
particular stakeholders in a given
setting and then we'll finish with a
couple of really interesting examples
that we've been wrestling with and that
perhaps help to crystallize from these
ideas one involves a so-called break in
series this is a major concern
statistical agencies have when they
consider using alternative data sources
integrating
into their production processes and
second another major concern centers on
disclosures limitations of the special
challenges that arise when we think
about using alternative data sources and
that risk that may be incurred in that
case so we'll begin with a little bit of
general background though overall most
government statistical agencies have a
mission statement that in some fashion
says the following our mission is to
provide the public with high quality
information on a sustainable and
cost-effective basis and a certain sense
that we spend on the rest of the half
hour here unpacking that relatively
short sense there's a lot of words
weighted with an awful lot they had to
flush that out a little bit we'll start
and say a little bit about our customers
we have certain key stakeholders and in
particular some of our published data
are motivated primarily and we're
originally mandated by Congress for use
by a particular stakeholder so for
example the Federal Reserve is you know
they had a meeting earlier this week was
a lot of discussion of that and when
they talk for example about levels of
prices talked about employment levels as
well some of the data that they're
referring to are produced by the bureau
of labor statistics as well as a number
of our partner agencies in addition to
that though we have a very wide range of
stakeholders from we're also trying to
serve needs for media is certainly one
example of that students both in terms
of analysis of microdata and also
students in terms of several basic
products like the Occupational Outlook
Handbook get a great deal of attention
as well as the general public so we have
a very wide range of stakeholders and
naturally they have a very different set
of needs as we think about different
stakeholders with that we have a wide
range of corresponding products that we
provide many of them are in the form of
tabular publications so for example in
the first Friday of every month we put
out an employment situation report and
the main component that unemployment
situation report is several sets of
tables describing both household and
business based measures of both
employment and unemployment both of the
overall national level and also for
specific levels at the level of industry
and occupation as well as some
demographic and
nation in the same way in the middle of
each month we produce a Consumer Price
Index again you see a one headline
number coming out of that but there's
also a lot of detail presented jalar
clean Tattler forms we also have Micro
data releases in broad public
dissemination these are primarily in
terms of households our survey data in
addition to that we have Micro day that
are made available for individual
researchers either coming inside the
walls of bureau of labor statistics in
some case or through our Federal
Statistical system research data center
structure that's for others to analyze
and that tends to involve people are
interested in very in-depth analysis
usually involving either generalized
linear models hierarchical models or
other types of models with about that
level of sophistication great deal of
attention devoted in those cases to a
very high level of condition it's going
to tie with the notions of value that we
have in a few minutes in addition we
produce some analyses on our own we have
a mandate as to our partner agencies to
be very strictly nonpartisan both in
terms of a data collection and in terms
of a publication and discussion so most
of our analyses tend to be of a fairly
technical nature for example work the
seasonal adjustment and other types of
work like that we do to quite a bit of
work I in that way and that often
informs both our current production as
well as our prospective future
production a lot of areas all of those
products are generally characterized as
called public goods in a sense that has
been developed both for statistics but
also for many other areas like national
parks roads other things like that you
know literature has developed over
roughly the last 50 to 60 years at the
interface between political science and
economics very rich literature have some
supplementary slides at the end if
you're interested in more detail but a
couple of 24 points I'll highlight for
the moment in terms of public goods is
we truly make this information available
to a very broad public on an even-handed
basis so-called level playing field in
addition fundamental feature of this is
that we want these data to be used as
widely as possible so we very much have
an open door in terms of that with some
conditions and restrictions that I'll
describe in a few minutes now
historically that mission and that set
of products have been focused primarily
on sample surveys and to some degree on
analysis
data related to administrative records
as well and in parallel without
historically both we and our partner
agencies have had a wide range of
quality measures that in some loose
sense have been focused on something
known as a total surveyor model
describing a little bit more detail in a
moment having said that in the last
eight to ten years there's been a great
deal of attention devoted within the
Federal Statistical system as well as
our partner agencies overseas to looking
at so called big data like we've been
hearing discussed here in the last day
and a half within the agencies and
within the general survey community this
is all sometimes referred to as organic
data I personally prefer the term non
design data it draws a distinction helps
to shed some light on characteristics
that we see with these types of data
relative to what we may have from
traditional sample surveys or
experiments other people use a very
broad term organic data sources Camille
alternative data sources as well give
you four examples of that just to fix
these a little bit in your mind these
are ideas relevant to the BLS but we
have very similar phenomena again
relevant to many of our partner agencies
one case is that we publish the Consumer
Price Index as I mentioned a moment ago
and there's a great deal of interest in
the SE and studying the extent to which
we may be able to obtain Consumer Price
Index in Consumer Price Micro data from
other sources than we currently collect
for example retail scanners like you
have AC Nielsen or IRA or particular
retailers directly from them information
in some cases that we collect through
web scraping we do a little bit of
production work right now with web
scraping but in principle we could do a
lot more in addition housing data
present some very rich opportunities for
our consumer price index housing series
another example involves employment
counts from private payroll process had
an interesting discussions lunch about
this private payroll processors have
information that they obtained from
their clients as they process payroll
information and in some cases also a
process benefit another type of in from
work for their customers
in parallel with that they have had an
in particular a couple of payroll
processors ADP as well as paychecks are
now publishing series related to that
ADP and paychecks covers somewhat
different segments of the US economy and
it's going to be very interesting to see
the extent if any to which we can
integrate that information with the
production information that we have
either for over a great estimates more
possibly for particular sub estimates
that we have for example for specialized
industries in addition at present
Conference Board publishes a Help Wanted
online index based on quite literally
online postings of job vacancies that
are available is again I was discussing
to some of you at lunch it's a
fascinating phenomenon because it is
quite literally lyrics related to
postings provides very valuable
information but does not necessarily say
as much about the exact number of
positions that are available associated
with particular posting this is
something we see frequently that we will
see nuances as we look at these
alternative data sources and again we've
seen a number of variations on that and
discussions that we've seen elsewhere
earlier in this conference in which we
have important elements available to us
from sydney's alternative data sources
but it doesn't tell us the full story
and a crucial question for us is to
assess the extent to which that
information is sufficient provides
enough value to our stakeholders or
whether we need to supplement that
information in certain ways to provide
all the information the valley that we
need to provide to our customers another
final example that was really
interesting the Susan Woodward about a
month ago presented at the joint
statistical meetings a discussion of
some small business both employment and
revenue data she had obtained from an
online accounting source and give a very
balanced and nuanced discussion there
about both quality features desirable
features as well as risks and
uncertainties related to those data
sources a particular number of
population coverage issues with that
they were terribly important in terms of
whether we'd be able to use those in
production at the bureau of labor
statistics are other agencies with all
of that and a whole lot of other
discussion we've had both
within VLS many other agencies we've
identified a number of really crucial
questions that we are exploring and
we'll continue to explore I'm sure for
quite a number of years the first one is
if in fact we use these alternative data
sources will we in fact provide equal or
better value for our customers and this
notion of value often ties in with the
idea that Anthony discussed earlier this
afternoon related to decision elasticity
if in fact you didn't have these data or
if you had them in a different form to
what extent for certain key stakeholders
or the general public would this end up
affecting the ways in which they make
decisions on essentially the quality of
decision they make related to that can
we understand that as we dig into that
further we usually see an important
distinction show up which is been
discussed in great deal of depth and the
public goods literature previously in
some cases we can evaluate this in terms
of a concrete very specific quote use
value unquote an example of this is our
consumer price index is used on an
annual basis by the Social Security
Administration to make a determination
about whether all of our parents
grandparents others who are receiving
Social Security are in fact going to get
an increase of how much for the next
year in terms of the basic social
security payment in addition the
Consumer Price Index is embedded in a
very large number of private sector
contracts in the United States we have
negotiated a certain price for this year
next year it's going to be that plus
whatever the Consumer Price Index went
up for in the same way our producer
price indices down at the individual
product level or used very very heavily
again a lot of contracts in the private
sector so that's it those are examples
of specific use cases in some ways
almost a mechanical use we are going to
plug this number in here as a result
we're going to get a particular outcome
there are also use cases that are
slightly softer than that but
nonetheless pretty well focused for
example many times we get inquiries from
a chief economist or somebody else in an
individual governor's office they say
what's fine that you're producing
national level information but they're
especially interested in estimates that
we produce at their individual state
level and we say okay help us understand
how using it and they say well we are
using your data in a Meccano metric
model because we have to give our
governor a forecast of what the total
revenue is going to be total tax
revenues are going to be for my state by
the end of the fiscal year if they get
that wrong they are going to have a very
unhappy government as well as a
legislature furthermore if they
underestimate the revenue a little bit
then they maybe catch it and they end up
having a little bit of extra money that
the governor of the state legislature
may be able to spend at the end of the
year for on the other hand states that
have a balanced budget constitutional
amendment you must balance this budget
by the end of the fiscal year if in fact
you have overestimated revenues and then
halfway through the year chief economist
has to go back and say I know you told
you that but you're gonna have a very
unhappy governor at that point they have
very severely asymmetric loss function
it's a really good example of how value
translates this necessarily translate
into in terms of traditional quality
measures we need to probe that further
to understand how those quality measures
tie in in a particular case for
particular set of users in other cases
it's better characterized use of our
data and the value that we convey to our
users is better conveyed as option value
unquote general idea of option value is
I am not necessarily using this
particular benefit right now but it sure
is going to come in handy if I ever need
to use it very simple example that's
often cited in the literature as
national parks I personally have never
been to Alaska but the fact that there
are some really nice parks up in Alaska
conveys a certain value to me right now
because someday I might use them in
parallel with that many of our
stakeholders again Federal Reserve other
users of our data one of the reasons
they are so interested in having certain
data series and having
continuity which I'll get into in a few
minutes is they say we want to be able
to have comparability of a large number
of series there may not be much going on
in a certain sector of the economy right
now but if in fact we start seeing
severe shocks in a particular part of
the economy we want to have a long base
for comparison give us much better
context to understand what may be taking
place at a given point the same is true
with an awful lot of methodological
features like outlier detection
robustness and other characteristics
like that Titan very closely with the
notion of option value we deliver and a
crucial question that our agencies then
have is the ways in which we can extend
traditional survey measures of data
quality now that we're thinking about
this wide range of non design for big
data sources and do that in a way that
is going to in an enriched fashion
address the fundamental value questions
that we have the value we're delivering
to our stakeholders see a little bit
more about data quality and in
particular traditional survey ideas and
then ways in which we ought to be able
to extend those to think about these
alternative data sources most of our
traditional serving agencies have a so
called multi-dimensional definition of
data quality and again this ties in
quite a bit with a number of comments
that we've been hearing in the previous
two days you the six to seven dimensions
that we typically see cited our
relevance accuracy timeless
comparability coherence accessibility
transparency and credibility there will
be an exam in a few minutes on those but
in fact those are just words there
really is a whole lot of content package
one of those I'm going to unpack that in
the next few minutes in particular the
fundamental question of relevance if you
try to explain that in a very broad
intuitive way good way to say that is
does this piece of a data or this broad
set of data series that I have does it
shed light on my high priority decisions
again goes back to the question of data
elasticity the answer was raising
earlier this afternoon in a more formal
sense people are as condoms and
statisticians will say tell me about
your variable specification tell me
about your model conditioning that
latter point is absolutely crucial
especially when you think about very
complex common metric modeling which
often is the most crucial part when
you're thinking about trying to shed
light on very complex policy issues
can't simply look at gross agar
you really have to look at very careful
conditioning again usually captured two
generalized linear models or
hierarchical models next component is
accuracy and again a quick intuitive way
to say that is if the report says X
whatever X's happens to be equals 2.4
are you sure how should are you in a
formal sense that ties it with the
notion of bison I mean squared error
point estimators as well as if we want
to be slightly more refined saying
something about both the size and the
coverage rate of interval estimates or
other types of estimated procedures that
we have that final point is especially
crucial when you have many stakeholders
carrying out very rich very complex
forms of exploratory data analysis often
you get people reading way too much into
a particular data set and having a
sophisticated refined understanding of
these notions of inferential limitations
in a complex data setting is really
crucial being able to do that first of
all for surveys is hard doing it for
alternative data sources going to be
even more challenging really good
opportunity another dimension timeliness
crucial question when you're talking
about timeless everybody wants things
faster but it's worthwhile to stop that
step back and say well faster can often
be more expensive and it can also convey
certain risk we've seen a couple of
reference to that earlier today the
crucial question asked is well are you
actually going to get a substantially
better decision if you truly have faster
data and that answer naturally is
depends on and in particular digging to
that a little bit more formal way you
really need to understand a lot about
the underlying rate of change and
particular measures and and the
associate decisions if it were a policy
decision or a decision by an individual
private sector organization for example
do I move into a market do I not move
into more can what kind of time scales
attached to each of those decisions and
the implementation and the resulting
impact all that's as crucial if we're
going to be able to understand the value
that we're conveying in a particular we
will see that depending on the phenomena
we're trying to measure
we have very different applicable time
scales in some cases Batali hurricane is
about to make landfall a few hours is
crucial timeliness is absolutely
essential in many of those cases in
other cases one example is epidemics the
Centers for Disease Control is focused
largely in growth of epidemics in a
matter of days on their scale and that
becomes crucial in addition on occasion
we see this in economic phenomena and in
particular during the financial crisis
in the autumn of 2008 when they were
anecdotal reports for example about many
small businesses getting their lines of
credit cut off by banks and things like
that it's something you could not
necessarily wait to get perfect data in
several months you had to be able to
work with whatever data you had
available on a given basis its ties back
into the notion of option value most of
the time for economic data that time
time scale may not matter but on
occasion it really does matter another
example is of all the infrastructure
investments as I mentioned a moment ago
we have at the bureau of labor
statistics published in occupational
outlook handbook this is used very
heavily by students making decisions
about what kind of career they might be
interested in going into and some
related information captured through
something known as the Occupational
Employment Survey is often used by
community colleges or other training
type organizations to make a decision
about should we in fact in our locality
establish a new training program in area
x that's something they're not going to
flip a switch on overnight and in terms
of the impact on the well-being and
employment prospects of individuals in
their community it's often a multi-year
in some case multi-decade before they
really see full fruits coming out of
that very different time scale and as a
result of that different time scale in
terms the information we're providing to
them comparability qualitative statement
is will they want to be able to compare
apples to apples that's fine as
intuitive qualitative statement but
often what we find is we have to dig
further too so to extend that met
or a little bit we say I want to have
some kind of apples to apples comparison
now what I really mean if I'm really
parsing things very carefully is I'm
going to be able to compare Red
Delicious with Golden Delicious apples
for example or maybe I'm slightly less
rigorous maybe I don't have quite that
demand for precision it's okay to
compare apples to pears okay they're
about the same size and they have kind
of the same texture or maybe i can
compare apples and oranges like either
about the same size but they're
definitely not the same texture well
maybe I can compare apples to
raspberries they're both fruit right
that in fact is a good analogy and it's
not frivolous because if we're counting
jobs all jobs for certain measurement
purposes are the same you're either
employed or you're unemployed in other
cases the exact work job requirements
for example skill requirements training
and other things like that really matter
so in some cases you may be discussing
difference between a Red Delicious in
the Golden Delicious in other cases you
may be putting apples and raspberries
together and so in a formal sense we say
we have to pay a lot of attention to the
value that is going to be conveyed to
our stakeholders by particular
conceptual and measurement differences
and sometimes they're looking for only
very coarse information other times
they're looking for very refined
information coherence is another
criteria Griffin idea is I got a jigsaw
puzzle or this pieces fitting together
or they in some ways just fundamentally
different from each other and just don't
fit together in an overall piece Alan
Greenspan when he was chair of the
Federal Reserve was absolutely famous
for both his congressional testimony and
otherwise pulling the pieces together on
the jigsaw puzzle from many disparate
sources some from federal government
data series from from from private
sector series is a real tour de force to
see in provide testimony on television
or otherwise from them in a formal sense
we can say what kind of context and
interpretation do we need to have for
specific practical uses again that's
where we're going to be able to convey
value is understanding what that need is
accessibility can I readily find and use
the data that I need we've seen several
presentations on variations on that both
in terms of having accessibility also
ready capture and display
that type of information final one
involves transparency and credibility
the qualitative level statements you
here I need to have all the cards on the
table I need to have a trusted third
party source that's especially important
when our data are being used by two
external parties for example in the type
of contract use of the Consumer Price
Index that I described before for that
purpose they want to have information
provided to them by an objective third
party source that's one of the reasons
the BLS and our agency spend so much
time at present on a lot of work in
presenting details related to survey
methodology and we will need to do
exactly the same sort of thing in
further depth if we're going to talking
about integrating multiple data sources
that means in turn we need to understand
an awful lot about that underlying data
source that we are using even if it's
coming from a source that may be in some
sense proprietary or otherwise subject
to certain intellectual property
restrictions that's going to be a
crucial thing because of this
transparency and credibility issue
finish with a couple of examples here
one example involves a break in series
when you talk to many people who are
responsible for production at the lsr
elsewhere and you say well should we
consider using alternative data sources
like again the cases that I was
describing before the usual response i
hear is we have an open mind on it but
we need to be very cautious about and
then they specify a number of things one
of the concerns they specify very
frequently in very legitimately involves
a so-called break in series for now in a
formal sense that means that I have a
certain estimator called theta hat this
might be for example for the
unemployment rate of the consumer price
index for a certain period t we say tell
me about the dentist ring that estimate
that you have and the underlying true
value whatever it happens to be are we
going to induce by changing our data
sources or changing our use of our data
sources are we going to induce your
experience a break in series a change in
the distribution probability
distribution of that difference between
truth and the estimate because we always
know there's some degree of difference
between there
that's a crucial question there's a lot
of literature on that the survey world
is something we're going to need to
study a great deal in this alternative
data source world also the main focus
has been on the level essentially the
bias and changing your bias structure
but in fact we also need to pay a lot of
attention we're going to be delivering
value to our stakeholders also tie that
in with changes in variance for example
we will often have a stakeholder says
yeah I'm mostly worried about bias and
then they pick up the phone and they
call us and they say gee this series is
suddenly jumping around a whole lot what
are they saying gee your variance seems
to have gone up or they may say most of
the time things are okay but it looks
like on occasion things are way out of
line essentially they're worried about
now liar and in fact whether we have a
sufficiently rigorous pattern of work
for outlier detection same is true for
seasonality some of you are aware it's
been a lot of discussion especially for
some of our partner agencies about
seasonality patterns and how they have
been changing largely in possibly in
response to the Great Recession often
when you dig further into that and you
think about a break-in series that may
be induced through the use of an
alternative data source crucial question
is what do we know about that data
source and have certain quality
characteristics of that underlying Micro
data source changed in a way that may be
undetected or not detected in a timely
way for example if you have an
alternative data sources based on
commercial activity as a customer base
changed for example you may have had a
provider that previously was focusing on
relatively large businesses now they're
moving in focusing on a mix of large and
small or vice versa we'd like to know
that in fact more than like to know it
we really need to know that because it
may have an effect on this break and
series phenomenon and we need to be able
to catch that ahead of time
also very frequently when we have
auxiliary information as I mentioned the
start of the talk we get some but not
necessarily all of the information we
need and consequently we need to be able
to link that at a micro data level in
doing that in many cases we need to have
an informed consent to Lincoln by the
person is providing us with these data
and in fact that is not something we can
compel all but one of our BLS surveys
are voluntary in nature our field force
absolutely moves heaven and earth to get
a high degree of cooperation where we
cannot compel that type of cooperation
nor can we compel consent and so very
frequently we're thinking about
integrating multiple data sources we
have to do an enormous amount of
modeling for a whole lot of reasons and
as a result that we need to evaluate the
quality that model fit in a particular
keep a careful eye on that because
underlying features the data may change
in terms of again both the source and
the measurement procedures that we have
and so we need to pay very careful
attention to probably the model fit as
well any one of those can cause the kind
of break in series phenomenon we have in
additional mentioned very briefly that
if we then think about how do we design
a system that is truly robust against
these types of shocks like a break in
series or otherwise when crucial
approach is to think about designs in a
code fault tolerant way the general
notion of fault tolerant designs was
developed originally in computer science
and engineering I believe many of you
are familiar with that that's something
that only on the very edges has begun to
filter into the sample survey and the
government statistics community but
something we need to be paying an awful
lot of attention to because in fact the
more we can make a design fault tolerant
in particular tune certain fault
tolerance characteristics vary directly
to the types of valley of the components
of value of the most important for our
customers it's going to be really
crucial for us to do that in addition
have a second example involving
disclosures limitation and I'll just say
a couple of words about this this is
reporting on some work by a couple of my
colleagues at the BLS Erika you and
Daniel to--the in particular the BLS
quarterly census of employment and wages
he is an administrative record data
source since the 1940s we have been
producing these series both for the
national
estimates involving basically employment
levels as well as aggregate wages but
there's also very strong stakeholder
interest in fine grained data down at a
relatively fine level of aggregation
involving intersections of industry by
particular geographical areas state or
metro area or in some cases individual
counties fundamental problem is that if
you're going down that very fine level
of aggregation you can have very
important issues related to disclose
limitation there are very serious legal
questions related to that and as a
result of that we find ourselves in a
conundrum of having one or two options
that we need to pursue at present when
we have a solid is problematic from that
disclosure point of view we end up being
required simply to suppress it an
alternative that we and our partner
agencies are exploring is to quote add
noise unquote to those data which means
you effectively take whatever the true
value is you can't release that for this
closure reason I had and so you
essentially add a certain amount of
noise on top of that good news is you
could produce something the bad news is
something looks advances but that's not
the real data and so it's a very tough
trade off and trying to understand this
is what Erika you and Daniel toes have
been doing is try to understand explore
with our stakeholders what those
trade-offs are in a particular what
particular cases they say I'm willing to
take some added noise in order to get
something published for that particular
cell crucial ideas behind that is to
look at particular use cases if you ask
them a general abstract question
generally you don't get a lot of
traction give them specific use cases
asking how exactly others data used and
what exactly is the impact of either
suppressing that cell we're not going to
give it to you at all or giving that
sell information but with some added
noise on top of that so in conclusion
we're very excited by the discussion of
use of big data or non design data for
efficient statistics I believe it's part
of a very broad and deep societal
reconsideration statistical information
it's been going on for several years
it's going to be going on for several
more decades involves a wide range of
issues regarding expectation on quality
cost risk as well as stakeholder utility
a lot of attention is going to have to
be devoted taking the tools we currently
have it extending them that's why it's
so exciting to be here and learn about
the tools that everybody else here is
using as well and also related questions
of resource allocation and in particular
it's very important that we think a lot
about extending measures that we have of
data
body and tying that in with notions of
stakeholder value that we're delivering
both in terms of use value and in terms
of option value thank you